l homme
[Musique]
bah en fait sortir de la rue st
vicié les modalités
l'indemnisation
quel son retour à l'emploi on
e
ça manque il
qu'attend aussi
dans les jambes ce temps
son père mais en france à amnéville
soyez
ça nous paraît à ses enfants
vermelles est possible
la forme est bonne
pour l'essayer
c'est sûr vivre de notre métier
pourquoi avoir choisi la couleur rouge
justement pour débattre en prétendant
que les femmes
j'en étais de femmes à travailler bien
parmi ce que vous voulez mais c'est bien
mais on reste majoritairement des femmes
les perturbe pas les serments il
confondu avec un gilet jaune doit alors
voilà ne pas faire l'amalgamé marine le
prix du contrat les réseaux ayant
commencé la présentation simplement non
peut pas être dans l'âme ou démarche
bestioles et dans une urgence d
gouvernement a décidé d'aller vite de
police
on n'a pas le temps d'attendre la fin
des grands débats et des discussions
urgentes